[Music]
than
we feel so
devastated hurt wounded it is it is the
worst feeling in the world to have your
child
murdered and then to have somebody else
say we're going to take possession of
these remains and we're going to put
them where we want to put them so we can
get more people to come into this Museum
and pay money so we'll make money on
this yes
okay well I I feel that it's that that
uh they're emboldened by this because
when you look in Texas where they want
to make Arabic uh a required language
when you look where where I live in
Bucks County Pennsylvania where you have
care going to the temples going to the
Quaker Meeting houses saying how
wonderful it is when you have H KH
speaking at CPAC I'm just saying there
is a problem and you have to stop them
here you have to stop them now because
you see what's happening around our
country right
now I am afraid that human remains of
your loved ones are seven stories below
ground behind a cold wall just that fact
alone needs to get out there's no way
that the media could not report this
once someone gets it out there I mean
that is chilling to the WR
it's a to a museum going to a carer's
office but because these remains are
unidentified for some reason the
families are not because we can't say
well that's my Joe or that's my
Sarah we don't have legal right to those
supposedly we're going to definitely
pursue this we going test that in the
course we're going to test it this is
the first time there's been such a mass
casualty of an an un identified remains
this is this is really going to set a
precedent of of whether museums are
allowed to display this yeah but they we
but but they're not Unknown Known I mean
they we we know who they are that's what
we're going to going to pursue it as a
class that's what we're going to purs
we're going to pursue legal action no
but we know who finite finite it's a
finite group of people that so that we
are going to pursue that it's
2,900 there's someone all the way in the
back there way way
back
yes I just I'm I'm from Los Angeles I'm
here with Jun William from RE patri I
just want to say
that I want to just say
um give my respects to the family of the
victims thank you and I want to salute
Robert and Pamela Pam and all the rest
of you here in New York cuz you are
literally at Ground Zero for the
nation um just to tell you what I've
tried to do in Los Angeles um we have on
911 morning uh called an event called
Sunrise vigil in which we try to about
5:30 in the morning try to time
everything with what you all are doing
here um we've been doing it since 2002
we did it again last year and we're
going to do it again this coming year
and I just want you to know that I was
in London at the time of 9/11 playing
Cricket over there and uh we got the
word from a phone call and we rushed out
to the bars watched on
television and um I felt so helpless all
we could do was we got a American flag
we went down to Chalo Square we stood
there with the American flag and stood
with you all um that's I just want you
to know that um we're doing what we can
to support you thank
[Applause]
you um I'm very sorry to hear that um
I'm an ex
mus and I lived for 34 years as a Muslim
converted 6 years ago to
Christianity um
unfortunately I can see what you're
looking for these are the Muslim hands
the hidden Muslim hands they are very
powerful and they're very
Wicked and uh just quickly to tell you
Islam is not a religion it's a political
movement and uh the followers of this
political movement their only mission is
to invade the whole world and to spread
the
Shar and to make it the only law on
Earth this this is what the book is
asking them for and you have only as you
mentioned three
choices Muslim or die or pay the gizia
and I don't think they will give you the
option of the
gizia um you Americans you're lovely
transparent and very innocent people you
have to learn the language of the enemy
to know how to fight
them
and you have to know that the word is
more powerful than this word and they
fear so much your word don't think they
don't care about it they go crazy when
they talk I mean when we talk about them
so keep it up spread the word we have
this internet media it's an honor it's a
pleasure you go on Facebook you just
type one sentence it spreads all around
the world so go ahead and do it
everybody
[Applause]
yeah I just wanted to say one word uh
you know thank you for your comments um
I I wanted to
give uh how I feel about uh why I'm
opposing the MOs Ground Zero a and that
is because I'm asking for sensitivity
I'm asking for sensitiv
for what the 9911 families
lost for the fact that 40% of them still
have no remains for the fact that our
lives and the lives of our remaining
children some of us don't have any
remaining children but even for our
remaining children our families are
fractured our lives are fractured so I'm
asking for sensitivity sensitivity to
what we perceive as a very hurtful thing
I I want to say say that uh you know in
my past uh um shortly after 911 I
created an organization called dis SKU
prayer safety campaign in memory of my
son and in that organization I have a a
dozen excellent advisers including
Professor Corbett who spoke here earlier
and I also have a
professor uh who whom I didn't even
realize uh until 5 years later that this
man was a Muslim and the reason I say
this is
because it was not a matter of religion
it was not a matter of intolerance it
was just a matter that we wanted to
change uh history and not allow
something like another 911 to happen and
and only after about 5 years did I
realize that this man who was an
engineer and and a person who felt such
sorrow for what happened who loves this
country who loved my son even though he
never knew him so I I want to make it
clear that myself and the other family
members it's this is not about a
religious War we want sensitivity but
we're not getting it we are not bigots
our children were loving open people I
mean they lived in New York like what do
you expect they were probably they were
so liberal and so t tolerant and yet on
911 they became instant
infidels and so my word is that we are
asking for sensitivity sensitivity to
what happened to this city to this
country and sensitivity for the feelings
of the 9/11 families and we have been
refused that we've been denied that and
I just wanted to say
that
at first I just want to say I thank you
for having this happen tonight and I'm
so sorry for all the losses for all the
families and I guess my feelings are I
grew up in Staten Island and to this day
I can't ride through Staten Island and
know that her remains are someplace
there that she has no proper burial
ground and my heart aches and heard all
of your words tonight about you feel it
every day and there's so many of us out
there our families are one whether you
were blood or thank you just a
friend and I guess my question that's
been burning all night is what can we do
if you have a geg order on you and you
can't speak freely and I'm not a family
member and so I received no conversation
and I have no one telling me I can't
speak who do we speak to this audience
is full of people who want to help I
just I just want to and we don't have a
gag order but the media has put a G on
us we don't have any power in the
media who are free to speak who can we
speak to well you know what what I would
suggest is and and someone had said it
uh uh before uh the pen is mightier than
the sword I would say to people if you
want to be proactive the best thing that
you can do is write a letter to the
editor of whatever newspaper it is when
there's anything you know you have to
respond to some type of article but
there's always articles about you know
911 or terrorism or the upcoming
anniversary write a letter to the editor
and certainly if if you can uh contact
your local elected official and say I
feel this way about 9/11 and and about
the people that died I I'd like you to
help me and I'd like you to stand up I
want to know your opinion I want you to
support the families that's what I would
say I don't know someone El not right
what you say I to say
something supposed to be family you
American you
American and you can R to president to
Bloomberg to maybe we have to ask help
from other country from England maybe
England will help
us Eng England is not going to help us
Eng it's to be let me say something
England's going to be the first country
in Europe that's going to go be an
Islamic State what we we don't the help
is in this room you need to it's not
that there's a gag order what what
you're seeing is the Press is self
enforcing the Sharia in Islam you cannot
defame you cannot insult Islam even if
it's true this is what har Builders was
told during his trial the Dutch Criminal
Court said it doesn't matter if what
you're saying is the truth what matters
is it's against the law what law is that
that's the law of of Islam it's the
Sharia it's blasphemy in Muslim
countries like Pakistan
Christians are being uh executed
executed for for throwing away a
business card of a man who's name was
Muhammad because he insulted blah blah
blah but the and they they they they
slaughtered they executed five uh like
this past month for blasphemy this is
blasphemy what we're doing in this room
is blasphemy now they're not executing
us what they do is character
assassination they destroy people they
destroy people's reputations they
destroys the the word of people they
marginalize people they demean people
this is what they destroy you this is
what they do uh you can write a letter
to the editor frankly I personally think
I'm not trying to I think it's a waste
of time I don't know how many letters to
the editor never get never get never get
R the but I will tell you what you what
you should do is you should always call
and write your councilman you should
always call and the mayor even though
it's a waste of time you have to make
noise and you have to to get involved
whether you like it or not we've been
living off the fumes of the greatest
Generation for a couple of generations
now I am telling you it's over it's over
you have to get involved now I know that
you're working I know that you can't put
in 20 hours a day on a blog blah blah
blah blah blah but you can do something
you wake up in the morning and you throw
your feet over the bed and you rub the
sleep out of your eyes and you say what
am I going to do today to save the
Republic you're going to send around uh
email to your email list you have each
one of you your own network you have to
get it around you saying I didn't know
that I didn't know that they're burying
the dead seven feet under people that
these loved ones can't can't can't mour
don't have a place to go why don't you
know because you didn't get it in the
email how'd you hear about the ground
zero Masque you didn't hear about the
ground zero Masque in the media how' you
hear about the ground zero mask who sent
you those pictures from the June 6th
rally it's you you keep looking to us
it's it's like darthy click your heels
together I want own my own backyard it's
you it's it's all you you have to send
it around you have to write you have to
get enraged you can make things happen
it is still America and our politicians
are supposed to represent us we have to
make it happen the media's never the
media is never going to tell our story
Pamela is going to have these DVDs I
think that it would be very powerful
for